This is Daniela Rus,
Director of MIT CSAIL
and Deputy Dean of
Research at the Schwarzman
College of Computing.
And I'm excited to welcome
you to the latest installment
of Hot Topics in Computing.
Today, we'll be chatting
with an important thought
leader in technology,
and in particular
in the area of fake data.
And this is
Professor Hany Farid.
Professor Farid is now on
faculty at UC Berkeley,
but several years ago we
were colleagues and friends
in the computer
science department
at Dartmouth College.
Hany is also a member of
the broader MIT community,
as he was a postdoc here.
And I would like to introduce
Hany's postdoc advisor,
professor Ted Adelson, who
will introduce our speaker.
Ted take it away, please.
Thanks.
So it is my pleasure to
introduce Hany Farid.
He has the distinction of being
one of the few people where
you can say he invented his own
field, which is digital imaging
forensics.
I'm pleased to be able
to say I was there
when he invented this field,
but it had nothing to do myself.
I was in my lab, working on
various more traditional image
processing topics and human
vision and computer vision.
And one of the great
things about Hany,
at that time, and
still today, is
that he has very diverse
interests and skills.
He's interested in
everything, and that
has turned out to be really
important for the work he's
done.
So this is just a little
bit before 2000, 1998 or so.
And people were
aware that the issue
of finding image
manipulation and fake images
was going to be an
important issue.
Nobody really knew
what to do about it.
Hany had some ideas.
I encouraged him to pursue them.
But when he told me
what he was trying to do
and how he was going to
do it, I explained to him
why it wouldn't work, and I
cited the relevant theorems
and offered counter examples.
But he persisted.
And finally, when he
demonstrated it worked,
I was convinced and
I was delighted.
And I also saw him give
a poster soon thereafter
at a conference, explaining
what he was doing.
And a famous professor
came to the poster,
started with a frown.
Explained to Hany
why it wouldn't work,
cited the theorems in the
math of why it wouldn't work.
And then continued
to do the poster,
and as he continued
in the poster,
he started smiling till the end.
He was like, wow,
that's really cool.
And occasionally,
at the conference,
I would go back to
see Hany's poster,
and I would watch as
the next person go
through the same thing, staring
with a frown and ending with,
oh, wow, that's really cool.
And so this is,
I think, typified
what he's done
through the years,
is time and again, through
his broad interests and skills
and creativity,
constantly found ways
to do things that everyone
thought was impossible,
and everyone could
prove was impossible.
And he continues to do
that today, and do it
in so many interesting ways.
And as we all know,
these problems
have become really
critical today.
So it will be very
interesting to hear
what he is working on now.
Take it away.
Thanks, Ted.
It's great seeing
you and Daniela.
Wonderful to see you
after all these years.
I'm only sorry
it's not in person.
So I'm going to
talk a little bit
about some of the most recent
work that we've been doing.
So hopefully you have
me in full screen.
I think you're in
full screen now.
And the work I'm going to talk
about for most of the talk
is that of Shruti Agarwal,
who's a really terrific PhD
student in my lab.
Graduating next year.
She's going to be on
the job market soon,
so everybody should
pay attention.
She is really, really wonderful.
We're going to talk
about deep fake videos.
You may have heard this term.
I'll define it for
you in a minute.
But let me just start with the
obvious, and where Ted started,
is that image
manipulation is not new.
I mean, as long as we've
been taking photographs,
we've been manipulating
photographs.
This, of course, is a
photograph of Stalin.
The gentleman to Stalin's
left had fallen out of favor
and Stalin apparently
thought that he could just
wipe this person out of
history by airbrushing him out
of the photo.
And so how did they do this?
Well, this is
obviously pre-digital
and so this is done
in the darkroom.
You take the negative and
you literally paint over,
and then you reimage and
you can alter a photograph.
And Stalin wasn't
alone, by the way.
You can look throughout history.
You see evidence of
photo manipulation.
And one of the
interesting questions
you want to ask
yourself is, well, why?
Why did Stalin go
to the trouble?
Why not just knock the guy
off and be done with it?
And I posit that it's
because people like Stalin
understood the power
of photography.
They understood the
power of visual imagery,
which is that if you can change
images, you can change history.
And while the
underlying techniques
from manipulating images
have changed dramatically
over the decades, that
fundamental concept,
that there is power
in visual imagery,
I don't think has changed.
Now, fast forward to
the digital age and we
can do lots of fun things
with digital images
in things like Photoshop.
So relatively easy
to create the photo
like this, where
Trump's face was spliced
on to the body of a child
that former President
Obama is holding.
And we've been able probably
to do this for about 10,
15, 20 years.
And as Ted was saying, when
I was working with Ted--
two, by the way, of the
best years of my career--
Photoshop was really
in its infancy.
Film still dominated
the landscape.
And I remember Ted and
I sitting in his office,
looking at a graph
showing the sales of film
cameras and digital cameras.
And just around the
time in the late '90s,
early 2000s was
the tipping point.
It was the 50% mark where
film was on the way down
and digital was on the way up.
And that's when I started
thinking about, well,
what happens when we enter a
landscape and everything is
digital and you can start
manipulating digital media?
And that sort of led on
to a two-decade question
of authenticating digital media.
And what happened over that two
decades is for the first decade
or so, it was really
digital cameras, Photoshop,
and things like this.
And I remember talking to Ted
about this many years ago,
maybe five years ago.
And Ted was saying, you know,
this is a great, little field.
It's a niche field.
It's important.
But it was small
and it was true,
but something weird has happened
over the last five years
with the misinformation
apocalypse that
is the internet now and
the role of fake images
and fake videos
and fake content.
And suddenly, what seemed to
be a relatively small field
has become much, much
larger, and we'll
talk a little bit
more about where
I see that in the coming years.
But in particular, what
has happened most recently
in the last few
years is that we have
gone from manipulating
things in the dark room
to simple manipulations
in Photoshop
to full-blown synthesis
using advances in machine
learning and big data.
So we're going to talk
about this, in particular.
So if you navigate to
thispersondoesnotexist.com,
you will be presented with
a single image of a person.
These are six images that I
grabbed off of that website.
And these are people
who don't exist.
They are completely full-blown
synthesized by deep learning,
in particular generative
adversarial network,
which I'll talk about in
more detail in a minute.
Unlike CGI, unlike
computer-generated imagery,
where you have a 3D model
and a virtual camera
and virtual light
and texture and hair
and highly, highly
detailed, that's not this.
This is a purely data-driven,
image-based technique
for synthesizing images
of people who don't exist.
And that idea of
computer-synthesizing images
or video or audio is what
is broadly called deep fake.
So let's talk about how
these are made very quickly.
It's a pretty simple idea.
Your job is to generate
an image with a face
of a person who doesn't exist.
And the way we do, that
is we have a generator.
The generator job is
to create an image.
They start by generating
a random image,
slap down a bunch of pixels on
whatever resolution you want.
Hand that image over
to a discriminator.
That discriminator
has access to a bunch
of faces of actual people,
scraped from the internet,
some database, whatever it is.
And the discriminator's
job is to ask,
can I discriminate this image,
handed by the generator,
from these images that are
known to be real people?
And of course, that
would be a trivial task
to do, in this
case, because that's
a bunch of random pixels.
Loops back to the generator.
Says, nope, it's not a person.
Keep trying again.
And eventually, after
enough iterations,
the generator will eventually
make an image of a person.
That person will be sent
to the discriminator.
And the discriminator will
say, yup, looks like a person.
So StyleGAN, StyleGAN2, other
techniques for doing this.
And they create highly, highly
realistic images of people.
And now we're even
starting to have control,
where you can play with
the gender and the race
and the age and the features
on it so it's not just
a random person, but you start
to have some controls on it
the way you would
in a CGI world.
Now, that's one type of
deep fake, a static image.
We'll talk a little bit about
where that type of technology
is being weaponized,
because that's
what the bulk of what
we're going to talk about,
is our deep fake videos,
is a deep fake video.
So now imagine taking that
same generative adversarial
network-- generative
because you're building
something, adversarial because
you're pitting these two
systems against each other.
And of course,
underneath each of these
is a deep neural network.
So now imagine we're going
to do something a little bit
different.
We're going to take this
image of Jennifer Lawrence,
the performer, and we
want to change her face
to be that of Steve Buscemi.
Why Steve Buscemi?
I mean, why not?
Anybody it could have been.
So now what we're going
to do is the following.
This generator has to change
her identity to his identity,
and it does it by
modifying some pixels,
handing it to the discriminator.
The discriminator says, can
I discriminate that person
from the actor Steve Buscemi
while keeping the appearance
of the image the same?
So his head should be
down and to the left,
his eyes should be
slightly closed.
The appearance of the
lighting and the texture
should be the same.
All I want to do
is change identity.
And again, you do this in a
very, very, very tight loop.
And if you do that
over and over again,
frame after frame
after frame, you
get something that
looks like this.
So original video is here.
A face swap deep
fake is here, where
Steve Buscemi has been mapped
onto Jennifer Lawrence's face.
There's actually an
audio track here.
I've just taken it out
so I can talk over it.
So a couple of things.
First of all, who would have
guessed that Steve Buscemi
is such a good-looking woman?
I mean, he looks fantastic here.
And notice how seamless this is.
The lighting looks really good.
The expression
looks really good.
The head movements.
Everything is moving, just
on every single frame.
All that has been done is we've
done a face swap deep fake,
frame after frame after
frame after frame.
By the way, if you haven't
seen some of these,
there are really, really
good examples on YouTube.
My favorite one just
came out a few weeks ago.
Sylvester Stallone and
Arnold Schwarzenegger
had been spliced into the
movie Stepbrother's, and it
is very, very funny
and very well done.
Slightly not safe for
work, but very well done.
So this is one type
of deep fake, where
we've replaced a
person's face, typically
from the eyebrows to the chin,
from one face to another.
There are two others.
Let me just mention them
briefly because I'll
talk about them later.
There is a puppet
master deep fake.
So here what we do is we take
a single image of a person,
and then I am the puppet master.
So as I sit in front of the
camera and move my eyebrows
and turn my head
and smile and talk,
it animates that single image.
There's a beautiful
work coming out
of the University of Southern
California from Hao Li's group
doing that.
A lip sync deep fake
is slightly different.
Here, we take an
original video and we
have a new audio stream,
either synthesized
or just an impersonator.
And all that we
synthesize is the mouth
to be consistent with
a new audio track.
So whether it's the
mouth, the entire head,
or just the face, each of these
deep fakes, what are we doing?
We're trying to make somebody
say and do something that they
didn't, either for
comedic purposes,
to interfere with a democracy,
or to commit large scale fraud,
by giving Zuckerberg to say
that his profits are down by 20%
and trying to move
the stock market.
So the game we play here is
we don't create these things.
We want to detect them.
Why do we want to detect them?
Well, because we think that
these can be weaponized.
So where are we currently seeing
weaponization of deep fakes?
Single-- I don't think it
will shock you, sadly--
single most common
use of deep fakes
is in the creation of
nonconsensual pornography.
A woman's likeness
is superimposed
into sexually explicit
material, and that material
is distributed online.
This is probably the
most common form of it,
and in fact, it is where the
term "deep fake" came from.
Deep Fake is the handle
name of a Reddit user
who used this
technology to create
the first nonconsensual
pornography.
Big, big problem for
performers, famous people,
but also a problem
for journalists,
human rights activists,
people who simply
attract unwanted attention.
There have been examples
of very high profile
cases of very powerful
women who have
tried to speak truth to
power and have been harassed
with this type of content.
It is awful and many
of the big platforms
have not figured out, or are
not willing to figure out,
how to contend with that.
We are all living through
highly complex and intricate
misinformation campaigns meant
to sow civil unrest, meant
to interfere with
democratic elections,
for the purposes of
trolling or for fraud.
And these types of
images and video
are simply adding
fuel to that fire.
So for example, my favorite
example of the use of a face
synthesized, using This Person
Does Not Exist, was last year,
a 17-year-old kid in Florida was
bored during his holiday break
and he created a fictional
candidate for Congress
in Rhode Island.
He got that candidate
approved by the election board
and got an approved
Twitter account
using a face of the candidate
that was synthesized using
This Person Does Not Exist.
He created a completely
fictional character
that, as far as anybody
knew, actually existed.
We've seen these types of faces
being used and misinformation
campaigns to create fictional
profiles on Facebook
and LinkedIn and on Twitter to
create credibility as people
create fraudulent accounts.
There are entire websites
now, by the way, where
you can pay somebody $1.99
to create any type of face
that you want, or you can just
download it for free from This
Person Does Not Exist.
As Ted will tell you, I
got into this business
because I was worried
about the courts.
So 20 years ago, we
didn't have the internet
that we have today.
We didn't have
nonconsensual pornography.
We didn't have even the
concept of fake news the way
we do today.
But we were worried about how
we introduce digital evidence
into a court of law, and
this creates a big problem
for how do we trust
the digital evidence,
whether it's an image, an audio
recording, or a video being
introduced into a court of law?
Obviously, on the
national security scale,
we are constantly, on a
daily basis, being inundated
with visual imagery from
around the world and places
that we can't
physically be, and we
have to make things
that have huge impacts
on the world around us.
How do we do that when we
don't know if we can trust
the visual imagery that we see?
Fraud, I've already
mentioned it.
I create a video of
Jeff Bezos saying,
Amazon stocks are down
10%, profits are down 10%.
How long do you
think it'll take me
to move the market a few billion
dollars before anybody figures
out that that video is fake?
We've already seen the
first example of this.
A CEO lost $250 million,
or 250 million euros,
because somebody had created
a synthetic voice over a phone
call saying, wire
this amount of money
per this person's approval.
They wired the money.
A quarter million was lost
from a synthetic voice.
So all of these things
are either here today
or we are probably going to
be seeing them in the coming
years, and this gives us
a little bit of concern
for how these types of deep
fakes can be weaponized.
And this is what we want to
think a little bit about,
is how do we detect these?
So I'm going to talk
about some of the work
that Shruti has been
doing on this front, just
one of the techniques that
we've been developing.
So I'm going to show you in the
next slide a series of clips
of former President Obama.
They are just a
short little two-
to three-second clips
from his weekly address.
I ripped out the audio
just so I can talk over it.
So you're going to see a
little clip after a little clip
after a little clip.
And in each one of those clips,
he's saying, hi, everybody.
Hi, everybody.
It's the very beginning
of his weekly address.
See if you notice
anything during the clips.
So every one of these, again,
he's saying, hi, everybody.
Hi, everybody.
Hey, everybody.
OK, so those are
all distinct clips.
I could have done that for
another 20 minutes or so.
And I don't know if you noticed
it, but every time he did it,
there's this little tilt of
the head up and to the back.
And you can see it here.
He's coming down.
So every time he says
hi, everybody, he
says hi, everybody.
And you can see it right
here on that slide.
He purses his lips
ever so slightly
and then he starts talking.
Almost every single
weekly address
he starts exactly the same way.
When Shruti first
showed me this--
this is actually a small
version of a longer version--
I was sure she had
duplicate in it
because it didn't seem like they
could have all been distinct.
Those are all distinct
little videos.
So what is that?
It's a little
behavioral mannerism.
It's a little tick.
I have mine, by the way.
I've been doing a
lot of Zoom talks.
I've been noticing them.
How I raise my eyebrows
when I emphasize.
I tend to move forward when I
want to emphasize something.
President Obama does
this thing where,
when he says, hey,
everybody, he does this.
He has other ones.
Let me give you an
example of that.
Here's my favorite one.
So what I'm showing
you here is one frame
from an authentic Obama video.
And on this graph,
what I'm showing you,
along the horizontal
axis, is time.
This is about 10
seconds, so roughly let's
call it 250 frames or so.
And in blue, I'm
plotting how much
Obama is rotating his head
around the horizontal axis,
as if in the affirmative,
nodding in the affirmative.
That's the blue graph
curve right there.
The orange curve is how
much he is frowning,
so the sides of his mouth
are turning downward.
And this is averaged over
an hour or so with video.
And what do you notice?
They're correlated.
So Obama has this
interesting mannerisms.
And you can see it
now, when you go back
and watch some of the
speeches, that when
he delivers bad news, when
he's angry, when he's sad,
when he's upset, he does this.
And he frowns and there's a
slight tilting of the head
downward when he speaks.
It's very consistent and it's
a very interesting, again,
behavioral mannerism.
Why do I care about
behavioral mannerisms?
We'll get to that in a minute.
But now let's think about
a lip sync deep fake.
So what was a lip
sync deep fake?
I replaced his mouth
with a new mouth
that has been synthesized,
saying something else
while his head was
saying whatever it was
saying in the original video.
Same thing, time on
the horizontal axis.
10 seconds.
Blue is rotation of
the head, up and down.
Orange is frowning.
What's wrong here?
They're decoupled.
Why?
Well, because the
head was saying what
the head was saying
in the original video,
but the mouth is saying, well,
whatever the mouth is saying
in the synthesized audio.
And although it looks all fine--
the mouth is doing what it
should be doing and the head
is sort of doing something--
I've carried this
chimera of sort.
The head doesn't know
what the mouth is doing
and the mouth doesn't know
what the head is doing,
and I've disrupted that
behavioral mannerism.
Now, that's Obama's.
This guy has a different
behavioral mannerism.
So same thing.
Time, 10 seconds.
In blue now is this chin
pucker that Trump does.
I actually can't
do it very well.
I don't know how he does it.
He does this weird
thing with his chin,
if you've seen him talk.
And the orange going
up here is this thing
he does with his
mouth when he talks.
And what you notice here is
that they're decorrelated.
So when he chin puckers,
his mouth is closed.
When his mouth is open,
he doesn't chin pucker.
Right there, correlated.
All right, Alec Baldwin doing
Trump in Saturday Night Live.
We created a face
swap deep fake.
So that's Trump's face
slapped on to Alec Baldwin.
What's going on
with Alec Baldwin?
Ah.
So he's got like the individual
characteristics of Trump, this
and the mouth, but
he correlates them.
So he's got that sort
of caricature of Trump,
but he didn't get the dynamics
right or the correlation right.
And so what we're going
to do is we're going
to explore various people--
Obama, Trump, Harris,
Biden, Warren.
Pick your favorite candidate,
senator, president,
prime minister, CEO,
whomever it is--
and we're going to learn
what their mannerisms are,
and we're going to try to
use that to distinguish them
from impersonators.
So fundamentally, we're not
really going after deep fakes.
What I'm going after
is whether it's
a face swap, whether it's
a lip sync, whether it's
a puppet master.
It's an impersonator.
It is whoever is
doing these actions,
either you've disrupted
the natural dynamics
of the head, the
mouth, the expressions,
or it's just not them.
It's somebody else
driving the mannerisms.
So here's what
we're going to do.
I think I've already said that
with the lip sync deep fake,
you disrupt what the
mouth and head are doing.
They don't know
about each other.
And for the face swap
and the puppet master,
it's somebody else moving.
It's somebody else's
mannerisms, even
if it looks like somebody else.
And we're going
to use that, we're
going to try to exploit
that, as a soft biometric
to distinguish real from fake.
So here's what
we're going to do.
Take a video, do
standard face tracking.
So here, the blue box
gives me 3D orientation.
The red dots that you
see around the face
give me facial features,
from which I will extract
18 so-called action units.
So these tell me, are you
lifting your eyebrows?
Are you frowning?
Are you smiling?
So these various
standard action units.
So for every moment
in time, as I'm
tracking that video over a
10-second window, roughly
250 frames, I extract these
18 action units and two head
rotations, rotation like
this and rotation like this.
We ignore this rotation,
around the vertical axis,
because politicians do
this a lot as they're
scanning the audience
and it's not diagnostic.
So we have 20
measurements that we make.
That gives us 22 [? 2, ?]
20 times 19 divided by 2,
190 pairs of expressions and
head movements, similar to what
I showed you for Trump, similar
to what I showed you for Obama.
Just look at the correlation,
or anti-correlation,
of facial expressions.
So every 10-second clip I
look at 190 correlations,
and I get a single
number off from each
of those 190 correlations.
So every 10-second
clip is now a point
in 190-dimensional space, which
of course we can't visualize.
I'm going to slam that into
this two-dimensional space here.
And every data point here
is a 10-second video clip
for Kamala Harris, Hillary
Clinton, Elizabeth Warren,
Bernie Sanders, et
cetera, et cetera.
So this work was obviously done
during the Democratic primary.
What do you notice?
Oh, by the way, all these
ones scattered in here,
these are random
people taken from
something called the
face forensic database.
It was part of a larger
testing that we were doing.
So you can ignore those.
But these clumps that you
see here are all individuals.
Even in this
two-dimensional space--
this is an, originally,
190-dimensional space--
you see this very
nice, tight clustering.
So Kamala Harris, all her
videos cluster together.
Obama, Arora, Booker, Trump,
Sanders, Warren, et cetera.
So how do we exploit this?
So what it tells
us, by the way, is
that people are
pretty consistent
and they're distinct
from each other.
We found this, if you
will, soft biometric.
And I say soft
because I don't think
I'm going to distinguish
Kamala Harris from seven
billion people in the
world, but I don't have to.
I just have to distinguish
her from an impersonator.
So here's what
we're going to do.
We do this in the full
190-dimensional space,
but we can visualize it here.
We build a simple, one-class,
non-linear support vector
machine.
Nothing fancy.
No neural nets, nothing
complicated here.
So we have a bounding surface
around the authentic Obama
videos.
And then any 10-second
clip, face track.
Extract the action units
and head movements,
190 correlations.
Put a point into this
space, and are you
within the bounding
surface or not?
If yes, authentic.
If not, not authentic.
And you notice, by the
way, these data points
are the deep fake Obama.
They're close, but
they're outside.
And if you're
outside of here, it's
not that you're a deep fake.
It's just that you're not Obama.
But that's all I care about.
If I'm looking at a video
and it looks like Obama,
I just want to know, are
the behavioral mannerisms,
are the temporal
dynamics unfolding over
a 10-second window, consistent
with the mannerisms of Obama
or Harris or
Clinton, or whomever?
So let me show you some
large-scale testing.
So we have a number of
different data sets.
I'll give you specific
numbers in a minute.
Original Obama,
super easy to get.
Just go on YouTube
and scrape YouTube.
You can get hours and hours
and hours of video of Obama.
We had some
colleagues and friends
up at the University of
Washington create some lip sync
deep fakes of Obama.
So now just the mouth
has been replaced
with a new audio track.
There's a very good impersonator
on YouTube of Obama.
This is not a deep fake.
It's just somebody
pretending to be Obama.
He's very funny.
From that, our friends at
the University of Southern
California, Hao
Li and his group,
created face-swapped deep fakes,
where we swapped Obama's face
onto the impersonator's video.
Yeah, they did that.
And then also, the USC group
made a bunch of puppet master
deep fakes, where one of the
graduate students in Hao Li's
lab was just sitting in front
of the camera, animating Obama.
So we have 1, 2, 3 deep fakes.
So those are the three
that I enumerated earlier.
We just have an impersonator,
because if we can detect
the differences, it doesn't
matter whether it's just
a real video but it's
somebody who's not Obama,
or it is, in fact, a deep fake.
And then, of course, we
have the authentic videos.
All right, so here's how I'm
going to show you the results.
I'm going to ask, what is
the ability to distinguish
authentic Obama videos, of
which there was about 207,000
10-second clips,
from random people--
these are primarily
newscasters--
the comedic impersonator that
I just showed you earlier,
and the three types
of deep fakes?
The numbers under each
of these are the number
of 10-second video
clips that we're
going to try to categorize.
Again, I don't have to
learn using this data.
This is pure testing data.
I train on this data--
authentic-- and it's a one-class
support vector machine.
So anything that falls
out is not Obama,
whether it's a random person,
a comedic impersonator,
or a deep fake.
I'm going to present the
results as area under the curve.
0.5 means I'm a chance.
I'm guessing whether
it's real or fake.
1.0 means I've got a
perfect classifier.
All right, let's see how we did.
OK, so for random people,
comedic impersonators,
face swap, and puppet master,
we're roughly an AUC of 0.95.
That's pretty good.
Not perfect, but pretty good--
on a single 10-second clip,
by the way.
That's actually not bad.
That's all I'm working
on, is a 10-second clip.
We took a big hit here.
We're at around a little
bit above 0.8 on lip sync.
Why is that, by the way?
Does that make sense?
So first of all, sure.
What's the nature of a lip
sync deep fake, because all
I've done is replace the mouth?
The rest of the head
is authentic, so
how he's moving his head
and his eyebrows is Obama.
In fact, most of the mannerisms
here are perfectly fine,
so it makes sense that
with these deep fakes,
and for people who are not
Obama, we should do better.
But here we do worse.
I won't show you
the slide for that,
but if we're careful
on the features
that we use, always
using one action
unit from the mouth and
another from the head,
this can bump up to about 0.95.
So if we're a little careful,
we can get a bump here.
But we can also get
a bump if we just
consider that most
videos that we see
are typically two
to three minutes.
And so if we just simply
integrate over all
of the 10-second clips in
a video, just averaging,
you can see you get this
nice bump in the dark--
I don't know what color
that is, blue let's call it.
So here, with the puppet master,
we have just about a 1.0.
We got a nice bump on the
lip sync to above 0.9.
And now we're getting
really close to perfect
classification, distinguishing
only using these behavioral
mannerisms over an average of
a two- to three-minute video--
two and a half minute
video, rather--
of Obama.
Now, that's for
Obama, of course.
I will tell you--
I don't have the slide
for this, apparently--
is that we've done this
for Hillary Clinton.
We've done it for Kamala Harris.
We've done it for Joe Biden.
We've done it for
Bernie Sanders.
We've done it for Donald Trump.
And the accuracies are all
almost exactly the same.
There's almost no difference,
except one exception.
We're really, really good at
detecting Elizabeth Warren
fakes, and the reason is she
is so incredibly animated.
If you ever seen her talk, you
are all from Massachusetts.
She is just really,
super animated.
Nobody can reproduce
that animation,
so we do really, really
well on Elizabeth Warren,
slightly better
than everybody else.
So this generalizes
to various people.
It's not just an
Obama classifier.
Now, I'm aware
that we are living
through a machine
learning revolution,
or I should say the third
machine learning revolution.
And I understand that
it's very popular to throw
machine learning at problems.
I think it's really
nice to understand
what it is that we've learned.
So it's nice that
we can look at this
and say, look, we've learned
this behavioral mannerism that
has to do with how
people move, for example,
their head and their mouth.
And for each individual,
I can tell you what it is.
I can go in and look and see
what are the features that
are most diagnostic.
So for Elizabeth Warren,
it's the head movement,
left and right as she talks.
Of course it is.
And for Trump, it's
something else.
And for Obama, it's
I'm also aware that we've
handcrafted these features.
We have, by hand,
selected things
that is almost
certainly not optimal.
But learning what
we've learned now,
let's see if we can
do a little bit better
by throwing some
machine learning at it.
So let me tell you a
little bit about what
we did, following on that
initial investigation, where
we got this idea
that we could use
these behavioral mannerisms
to detect impersonators
and deep fakes.
So here's what we're going to do
to try to tidy this up a little
bit and eke out a little
bit more performance.
We're going to
start with FAb-Net.
So FAb-Net is a
deep neural network
that captures the
appearance of people.
And basically what it does,
it takes a single image
and it extracts a
256-dimensional vector
that represents a
person's appearance.
Now, we care about
time, so here I'm
going to have T equals 1 to 100.
So that's 100
frames now, so we've
reduced it down to about four
seconds from the original 10.
We did that primarily for
computational considerations,
because once you
start doing everything
with neural networks, it
gets a little more tedious.
So we're now only working on
four-second video clips, 24
frames a second, 100 frames.
Each one of these gets
shoved through a FAb-Net.
What does FAb-Net do?
This representation right here,
this 256-dimensional vector,
is a representation of
a person's appearance,
so that if you do a query
against a database of faces
using that representation,
you will get things
that have a similar appearance.
So for example, here in
the middle row, this woman,
her lips are slightly pursed.
She's looking directly
at the camera,
and her eyes are closed.
The nearest neighbors
that you see to the right
here using that
representation are, well,
people who sort
of look the same.
But it's not the same
person, most importantly.
Here, for example, the person
with this slight profile,
and nearest neighbors are
people similarly profiled
but different identity.
That's the whole
point of FAb-Net,
is that you are capturing some
characteristic that embodies
the appearance of the image.
So that's not
exactly what we want,
but it's a step in the right
direction of what we want.
So what we do is we take each
frame across four seconds.
We shove them into
FAb-Net and we
get this 256-dimensional
representation.
Now, what do we want to do?
We want to capture
behavioral mannerisms.
So we really want time in there.
So that FAb-Net is one step.
Why?
Well, if my head is turned
this way and I'm frowning,
that's an appearance.
But then what happens
in the next frame?
Ah, I start to smile.
OK, so I want to capture that
change in appearance over time,
but I also care about identity.
So here's what
we're going to do.
Take the 100 frames.
Each one goes through FAb-Net.
You get 256-dimensional
representation.
Pack that into a matrix.
So now it's 100 by 256.
That's this step right here.
We're going to shove that
representation into something
that we built
called Behavior-Net.
So that's that little
green box right there.
And out of that comes
512 dimensional vectors.
I'm not going to talk about
all the nitty-gritty details
about this.
I will give a link at
the end of the talk
with a paper that
describes this.
A couple of quick things.
This is a standard
architecture using ResNet-101.
We use a metric learning
objective function
and a VoxCeleb2 data set.
And what we were trying
to do was the following.
The objective here was
to do the following.
Given not just a single
image, but 100 images,
four-second clip, we wanted
to find similar clips in terms
of identity and appearance.
So for example, here, in
that little video clip,
you can now see The Rock is
moving and this person moving.
There's 100 frames.
Out of those 100 frames,
we push him into FAb-Net.
We push him into
our Behavior-Net,
and out comes a
512-dimensional representation.
We then look for the nearest
neighbor in the big data
set of videos and images that
we have and we extract the most
similar.
And now you see something
really interesting.
You see, first of all, it finds
the same person and the thing
that they are doing is similar.
So here's The Rock at
slight profile talking.
Here's this guy.
He starts talking and
he turns his head.
The nearest neighbors
do the same thing.
Same thing on this one.
This woman is talking, and then
she turns her head slightly.
Nearest neighbors
do the same thing.
So the output of
the Behavior-Net
is now capturing two things,
identity and behavior.
Well, that's what we want.
So instead of hard-wiring
the action units and the head
movements, we're now going to
use that learned representation
from Behavior-Net, and I'm
simply using this visualization
to tell you that that
Behavior-Net seems
to have learned the
representation that
captures both identity
and behavior mannerisms.
All right.
So that's one pipeline.
Everybody goes into
FAb-Net in the blue.
FAb-Net goes into this
Behavior-Net, that little box
there.
Could be a whole other talk,
talk about how we did that,
but I'll ignore it for now.
A 512 representation, that
captures the underlying
behavioral mannerisms.
Let me just describe
another pipeline
because we're going to combine
a few things in the end.
Each of these image is then
shoved into a VGG, which
is a standard face recognition.
Out of that comes a
496-dimensional representation,
which you can just use
for face recognition.
There's nothing
special about VGG.
We just use some off
the shelf representation
for face recognition.
We get 100 of those for each
of the frames of the video.
We simply do an average.
Why?
Well, because we expect the
face to have the same identity.
So out of this pipeline,
in orange, comes identity--
spatial, static identity
based on face recognition.
Out of this pipeline
comes behavioral identity,
having to do with the
mannerisms evolving over time.
And now what we want
to do is we have
a reference set of
authentic videos,
where we know who it is.
We know what the mannerisms are.
And we simply ask a
very simple question.
For this sequence, there
is an identity match
based on the face.
This is Kamala Harris.
We have a match based on
the behavioral mannerism.
Who is the closest, in terms
of the mannerism, of this?
And then we simply ask,
well, is it the same person?
So does the mannerism
match the face?
And if the answer is
yes, it's authentic.
And if the answer
is no, then we say,
OK, it looks like Kamala
Harris but it's not
moving like Kamala Harris.
Mismatch.
It's a fake.
So that's what
we're going to do.
Now, let me just show
you the evaluation.
So we had a couple of
different data sets.
What I'm plotting on here
are 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 data sets,
in terms of the number of
identities in the data set
and the average
duration of the video.
This is the data set that
we created that I was just
talking to you about.
WLDR stands for world leaders.
There's only 10
identities, but we
have 14,000 seconds
per identity,
so we have really long
sequences per person.
This is the face
forensic database,
which has 10,000 people but
only 19 seconds per person.
And then there's a few
data sets in between
that are somewhere in between.
We're going to evaluate the
Behavior-Net that I just
described across all
of these data sets.
This time I'm going
to present the results
in a slightly different way.
This is the average accuracy
across all five data sets.
Along here is a parameter,
just a threshold
that allows us to know when
we should make a decision.
And this is the percent correct.
I fear that this might
be a little small.
100% is at the top.
0% is at the bottom.
Crossover point is roughly
97%, across all the data set.
So you can see
here 97%, 99%, 98%.
Oops.
88%.
I'll get back to
that in a minute.
And 93%.
So you can see the crossover
for real in purple and fake
in green are in the high 90%s.
I don't have a slide, I'm
sorry, to do a comparison
to the original technique.
But I will tell you,
we get a 5% to 10%
bump, relative to the
handcrafted features.
Not as much as you would
have expected, by the way.
I expected the machine learning
would have learned a much more
diagnostic and
representative feature,
but in fact, it's a
relatively modest bump
after all of that work.
Now, we took a
really big hit here.
We went from the high
90%s to the high 80%s.
And why is that?
What is it about this data set?
And I like this plot
a lot because it's
a cautionary tale
when you're using
these big data sets that you
download from the internet.
So this is one example from
the data set, the DFDC data
set, which was built by
the folks at Facebook.
So these were meant to
be face swap deep fakes.
This is one frame
of the source video
and one frame of
the target video,
and this is the corresponding
frame of the face swap.
Now, what this should have
been is this person's identity
mapped onto that
person's mannerisms,
but that's not what happened.
All this is is a blurry
version of this person.
And so this face
swap is, in fact,
not this person's identity.
It's still this person's
blurry identity.
And so, in fact,
this database is
riddled with some problems,
where the face swaps just
failed.
And because there's thousands
and thousands of them
and the quality control
wasn't done very carefully,
they're out there.
And so when you're
evaluating against these,
you have to go back and
look at your mistakes,
and it turned out the data set
was actually not very good.
And if we eliminate all these,
we get back into the high 90%s
again.
Just a little bit of
a cautionary tale.
So that's one technique
that Shruti and I
have been working on.
Let me talk a little bit about,
going forward, what's next.
So what are the
challenges in this space?
I think everybody
here probably knows
that really rapid,
startlingly rapid advances
in deep learning.
So every three to
four months, frankly,
every time there's a
conference deadline,
we see new advances in the
synthesis of fake images,
fake video, fake audio.
It's a very, very
fast landscape.
The problem is not, of course,
just creating fake content.
It's the fact that that content
can get online and spread
at a speed that is unprecedented
because of social media.
So if the problem was just
we can create fake content
but we have no way
of distributing it
to the world
instantaneously, well, OK,
it'd still be a problem.
But this is the
biggest problem, which
is at once this
stuff is out there--
once the nonconsensual porn,
once the misinformation,
once the fraudulent
content gets out
there-- it is very, very, very
difficult to rein it back in,
and that's a huge challenge
for us working in this space.
We have a particularly
polarized public,
that when videos
come out, people want
to believe that they're fake.
So for example,
when George Floyd
was killed by a
police officer, people
claimed that it was a
fake video because they
didn't want to believe it.
When the video of
Speaker Pelosi came out,
purportedly showing
her drunk, people
wanted to believe that she was
drunk, despite the fact that it
was fake.
And so when you have a
highly polarized public,
you can very easily play into
people's preconceived notions,
and this stuff works because
people want to believe it.
The biggest threat
here, I would argue,
is what is called
the liar's dividend.
So this is a lovely description
from Danielle Citron
of what happens when
you enter a world where
any image, any video, any audio,
any news story can be fake.
Well, then nothing
has to be real.
Anybody can simply
dismiss something
as inconvenient truth.
Here, by the way, is how
fast the world has changed.
Rewind with me, if
you will, to 2015.
Then candidate Trump gets
caught on an Access Hollywood
tape saying some very, very
bad things about women.
What did he do?
He apologized.
He actually said the
words, I am sorry.
That was wrong.
It's not who I am today.
Two years later,
2017 now, a reporter
asked about the
Access Hollywood tape.
You know what he said?
It's fake.
One swipe of the hand, gone.
That's how fast the
landscape has shifted
and people's ability to say,
you can't believe anything.
Whether it's the New York
Times because they're
too liberal, whether it's
Fox News because they're
too conservative, or whether
the facts simply don't conform
to your worldview about the
number of deaths of COVID,
about humanitarian
crises around the world,
about climate change, about any
of a number of things happening
in the world, you don't
have to believe it
if you don't want to because
once everything can be fake,
nothing has to be real.
I would argue that is by
far the biggest threat that
is emerging on the landscape.
The net-- Ted knows this very
well because Ted and I have
talked about this many times--
is this is an arms race.
We do a little bit something,
you do a little bit something,
and the game keeps going
and we never, never quite
end this game, like everything
else in cybersecurity.
So it's both fast-paced
and never-ending.
What are the interventions?
Well, I think that the
YouTubes and the Facebooks
and the TikToks and the
Twitters of the world
have to start taking more
responsibility for the mess
that they've created in society.
They have to stop
standing behind
"we're simply the platform.
We are the wire.
We're not responsible."
I don't think anybody
believes that anymore.
We have to find a
balance between dealing
with the misinformation
apocalypse that is among us
and having the free
and open internet
that we all want
to exchange ideas.
I think as we are talking about
regulation-- which is happening
here on Capitol Hill.
It's happening in Brussels.
It's happening in the UK.
It's happening all
over the world.
I would argue that we should
spend more time talking
about the recommendation
algorithms and less time
talking about the content.
The fact is that the reason
we have the problem today
is not because you can
create fake content,
not because you can post that,
but because the underlying
recommendation algorithms
favor the most outrageous,
divisive, hateful,
conspiratorial content
because it's good for business.
Hate and outrage sells.
It keep people engaged.
Engagement keeps you clicking.
Clicking is good for revenue.
We should be talking about
recommendation algorithms
more than we should be talking
about the underlying content.
Obviously, we need to be
talking about technological
interventions, and
obviously we need
to be talking about
how do you educate
the next generation
of young minds
on how to be better
digital citizens
and consume trusted
information online.
This is Shruti Agarwal.
Really, really wonderful
student, who's done all the
work that I've described and
many other really beautiful
things in the general
space of digital forensics.
Let me just touch on a few
things happening in the lab,
just to give you a flavor
for some of the other things
that we are working on.
Sophie Nightingale
is a former postdoc.
She just started a job
yesterday, in fact,
at the University of Lancaster
in the UK as a professor.
Sophie has been doing some very
nice work over the last two
years on forensic
identification,
how we identify people
from crime scenes.
She wrote a really
beautiful paper
in the proceedings of the
National Academy of Science
this year, showing that a
technique used by the FBI
in actual cases over
the last few years,
trying to identify people from
the wear and tear on blue jeans
is highly unreliable, despite
the fact that the courts have
adopted it.
And more generally, we
are interested in how
these various digital
forensic techniques are
being used to identify people,
whether it's based on things
like clothing, or as
Neerja is working on,
even simple things, like
estimating people's height
and weight from a
single photograph,
turn out to be
highly unreliable.
So we have a big
emphasis in the lab
not just on whether
things are real or fake,
but on how you can extract
reliable information
in a forensic setting
to identify individuals.
One quarter of wrongful
convictions in this country
are due to flawed
forensic science,
both physical and digital.
That field is a bit of a
mess, and Sophie and Neerja
and I are trying to understand
what the landscape looks like,
figure out what are the
techniques that are reliable,
what are not, and how to
make them more reliable.
Julia Dressel was an
undergraduate with me
at Dartmouth College.
And this work is
now a few years old,
but I wanted to mention
because it's also
in the general space
of criminal justice.
Julia did a really beautiful
undergraduate thesis
in understanding the use
of predictive algorithms
and predicting recidivism that
are being used in the courts
today, both here in
the US and abroad,
and how these algorithms
have a serious racial bias,
and understanding where
that bias is coming from
and when and if it can
actually be corrected.
And there's some really nice
work in a Science Advances
paper that Julia wrote
a couple of years ago.
Everything that
I've talked about,
Shruti's work on the
digital forensics,
Sophie's work and Neerja's
work on the forensic science,
and Julia's work on
algorithms can all
be found at that website,
farid.berkeley.edu.
And I think with
that, I'll stop.
Thanks very much.
Thank you very much, Hany.
That was really wonderful.
I'm going to give
you my applauses.
Lovely.
So let's see.
We have a question,
a technical question.
What do you use for
dimensionality reduction?
Is it PCA?
Yeah, we did not use PCA.
We used the t-SNE.
OK, t-SNE.
I don't think, by the way, there
was anything special there.
I think you could have used
just about anything for that.
But I think t-SNE gives you
slightly cleaner results.
Fabulous.
I would like to ask you a
more conceptual question.
So how can we imagine a
technological solution
for dealing with
this whole fakeness?
We have spellcheckers and
we have fake checkers.
What would it take to get there?
Good.
I'm glad you asked this.
Let me preface this
answer, Daniella,
by saying that the technology
I'm about to talk about
is related to work that I do
with a small startup, in which
I have a financial interest.
I have a little bit of
conflict of interest
in what I'm about
to describe to you,
and I think it's
important to mention that.
So everything I've
described is what
falls under the category
of passive forensics.
You wait.
You sit back and you wait
for the video to hit,
and then you try to figure
out if it's real or not.
And that works
reasonably well when
it's the New York Times
or the Associated Press
or Reuters that
are willing to wait
days or weeks to get it right.
Or it works well in
the courts of law,
where you have days, weeks,
months, years to get it right.
But it doesn't work well on
Twitter, Facebook, YouTube,
and TikTok, where things
move at light speed.
So how do you get to
what you just said?
I like that analogy, by
the way, the spellchecker.
That's exactly the right
way to think about it.
So the passive
forensics are never
going to get there,
in my opinion.
We're never going to have
the accuracy and the speed
to be able to analyze any type
of image, any type of video,
or any type of audio at scale.
It's not going to happen.
So what can you do?
So the work that is being
done that I think can scale
is so-called control
capture imagery.
So here's the basic idea.
It's quite simple.
On this device, at
the point of capture,
either in hardware software,
you reach into the image
and you grab all the pixels.
You grab the GPS tag and
you grab the daytime tag
and you cryptographically
sign it.
You take that
signature and either
you just attach it to
the image or you put it
on to a blockchain
type of thing.
And then any point
in the future,
you can authenticate the
image back to the original.
So it's not a watermark.
We're not inserting something
into the image, which we all
know has problems because
those can be removed,
but it's a
cryptographic signature.
If somebody wants to remove
the signature, it's fine.
You just won't be able to
authenticate the image.
I think that's
one technique that
could actually work at scale if
it was on every single device.
And the good news
about these things
is this is where, what, 99.9%
of photos are taken today?
We're all taking photos
on these devices now.
They're all HD cameras.
I bet Ted is probably
taking photos on these.
So I think that technology
can scale and it can work.
Now, there are
limitations to that.
There are things to worry about.
There are privacy
issues to worry about.
But if you think about the
direction, it makes sense.
It doesn't make sense
for me to take a photo
and send it to the
world and ask everybody
receiving it to fact-check it.
That's insane.
What makes more sense is
for me to take a photo,
authenticate it, and then
put it out to the world.
So that is the technology
that I think could work.
But now what do you need?
You need Apple and Google to
build it into the devices.
You need the Facebooks
and the YouTubes
and the TikToks and the
Twitters and the social medias
of the world to
prioritize that content,
to say we will prioritize
trusted content
over non-trusted content.
And then you have to deal with
a couple of very tricky issues,
which is Human Rights Watch.
What do you do with an
investigative journalist,
a whistleblower,
or somebody who's
doing human rights to make
sure that they are not somehow
being exposed?
And you've got to figure out
how to add in some anonymity
to that.
That technology exists
today, but there's
a lot of infrastructure
that would
have to get built around it.
Thank you, Hany.
We have just a few more minutes.
I want to sneak in two more
questions from the audience.
Can you generally tell
if a picture is fake just
by trying to identify
pixel overlays?
By identifying pixel overlays?
I'm not sure exactly
what that means.
So let me answer it this way.
We have a number of
different techniques
for detecting image manipulation
that work at that pixel level,
that look at things
like, has this
been compressed more than once?
Is the color filter
ray bear pattern
consistent across the image?
Do you see inconsistencies in
the underlying image noise,
for example?
So the answer to that is
sometimes yes, sometimes no.
The problem with those
really low level, pixel level
detection schemes
is that if somebody
takes an image, HD, manipulates
it, and then downsizes it
by a factor of eight
and compresses it
to 75% JPEG compression,
all of those artifacts
disappear and you introduce
all these gnarly JPEG
artifacts, which make those
very difficult to detect.
Hany, one last question.
Do you have any
thoughts about detecting
fake audio or fake speech to
complement the fake video?
Yeah.
We've done some
work on fake audio
with one of my former PhD
students, Wei Lu, who's
now at SUNY Buffalo.
I have to say--
I'm embarrassed to say this--
I always thought that when
I went to go do speech,
it'd be really easy, because
video seems really hard
and image seems hard,
but not as hard as video.
And I just figured,
as I moved down
the dimensionality
it would get easier,
but audio is
really, really hard.
We have developed
some techniques.
I think it's somewhat
of an orphan field.
Most of the people in my
field don't look at audio,
and I think it's really
ripe for a lot of really
interesting questions.
So we've done a little bit.
There's a few papers
on my website about it.
There's a little
bit of a literature,
but it's a little
neglected, in my opinion.
Hany, that was really wonderful.
First of all, great to see you.
Second, I was so excited to see
the really insightful research
from your group.
Thirdly, I look forward
to a better world
where I will have the
fake catching system
so I won't have to worry about
fake images and fake videos.
Really, thank you very much.
On behalf of all of us,
I'm going to give you
another round of applause.
And maybe you can stay
on for a few minutes.
OK.
Bye, everyone.
See you next week.
Thanks, everybody.